you can watch this and other programs
online at book TV org dr. Helen cherski
is a physicist and an oceanographer and
a regular science broadcaster on the BBC
from a PhD focused on experimental
explosive physics she's gone on to
explore the optics and acoustics of
ocean bubbles and their influence on the
atmosphere from her post in the
Department of Mechanical Engineering at
the University College London University
College London dr. chaski writes a
monthly column for BBC focus magazine
where she addresses the little questions
that spin up into big ones stuff like
why is blueberry jam actually more pink
and why does milk swirl like a storm
when added to hot tea these observations
the physics of everyday life are the
foundation of her first book storm in a
teacup please join me in welcoming dr.
Helen cherski
so you may be wondering why the book is
called storm in a teacup but the title
very clue says we need to talk about
physics and that is because we do I'm a
physicist people do not talk about
physics enough they do talk about
physics quite a lot in popular culture
but they don't talk about the bits that
I care about so we're going to talk a
bit we're going to talk about the pinch
that I care about and I am I'm a
physicist based now in London I did work
in the States for many years I sort of
became an oak part in oceanographer by
the back door I've done lots of
different bits of physics but I identify
very strongly as a physicist but I do
all these other things as well they're
not mutually exclusive and I'm not going
to talk about my job very much but just
in case you're wondering bubble
physicist is a real job very important
that you know that and so physics right
as a physics degree I did three I think
and this is the sort of popular image of
physics right I've just written there's
people off to the sides especially over
there might not be able to see very well
there's not the pictures aren't that
important don't worry and so this this
is a classic image of physics for those
who can see it it was taken at something
called the Solvay conference in 1922 and
this was when the big ideas of quantum
physics were battling it out they'd
realize the Victorians thought that
physics was all just mechanisms notes if
we just it would just been tidying up
needed around the edges and then it
would all be okay
and then quantum physics became
necessary and this sort of thing
happened these big conferences of all
these great minds who you will notice a
mostly old white men Mary Ann Marie
Curie's on the front row they let her in
but grappling with the nature of
determinism and what it meant not to
know exactly where a particle was at any
moment in time so there's a lot of suits
a lot of ties a lot of beards and lots
of quite grumpy looking people to be
honest so so that's that's sort of the
picture of who does physics when it
comes to what fizzes either physics is
it starts to look like this thing down
here now anyone who can read this
language will recognize that these are
wave equations and they're describing
particles and to everyone else it just
well
quite pretty right but it's complicated
this is accessible and it is another
language and and that's not the sort of
thing you can just you know appreciate
without without you know having studied
a little bit and then there's things
like that so this is an artist's
impression of to collide to
gravitational fields surrounding two
colliding black holes and that's just
weird and then this thing is a load of
lasers and I'm RELIGIOUS just blood I
didn't have to write the risk assessment
for whoever cut photographed because if
a laser safety officer walked in and saw
that you would be sacked tomorrow so
yesterday so this the point is that this
is a picture of physics it it's obscure
and it's done by a slightly weird people
and it's far away and it's complicated
and it's not here well I'm a physicist
and I study this which is the surface of
the ocean so I study the way that
breaking waves and bubbles at the ocean
surface help the ocean breeze and the
surface of the ocean is a fascinating
place it sometimes looks like this you
will notice sometimes people ask me I've
got friends who you know marine
biologists and things like that and they
occasionally gone with them to study
you know nice tropical reefs in hot
places that is not what I do I study the
North Atlantic in storm season so this
is as colorful as you ever get and so
but you know let's worry about the shape
not color so the ocean surface sometimes
like but looks like this and I go to sea
and look at it and sometimes it looks
like this and I studied it what's
underneath these white patches and
sometimes it looks like that and
sometimes it looks like that and this is
physics right there's no doubt that
whatever describes this process is
physics but it's not included in that
you know sort of that sort of popular in
the traditional view of physics but it
does count and it counts for a very
important reason and so I do do this I
am told it's called hosting here we call
it presenting documentary science
documentaries and a few years ago a
director we'd arrived at were on the
coast
we wanted to talk about breaking waves
the BBC didn't have any money so instead
of sending a
somewhere pretty with breaking waves
they've sent us to the far side of
Cornwall in January and anyone who's
been there will know that it's a lovely
place is quite cold anyway so because I
was shivering director sent me off to
sit on a rock and he said you go over
there Helen and think about the thing
you most want to say about physics and I
now I look back and I'm like he was just
trying to keep me quiet and from
complaining about the cold you just go
off of that and you work out the thing
that gets you most you know the real
thing that you're interested in when you
think about physics and so I totaled off
to the rock and and it occurred to me
consciously for the first time that the
thing that has always interested me most
about physics as a subject is this idea
of patterns that it's not about learning
a pile of facts I mean you've got to
feel sorry for the biologists have you
seen how many types of frog there are in
the world right it's not just about
learning all the different types of frog
and physics fundamental is about
patterns and it's about patterns that
pop up in this again and again and again
and again so for example the same little
pattern in physics explains cake the
internal combustion engine hot air
balloons katabatic winds of antarctica
and popcorn and all of those things come
from one tiny tiny little physical idea
and I promise this the only equation I'm
going to show you but is this right so
don't you like equations it's not even
if you don't like equations very much
and it's quite nice right spring the
equation but it basically relates the
pressure and the volume and the
temperature of a fixed body of gas and
once you know just a little bit about
that and the idea that if you have a gas
and you it is a fixed temperature and
you reduce the volume then the pressure
of the gas increases it's that sort of
thing so that one little bit of physics
get you to all of these places and it
worked this is this is almost
universally applicable you can you can
find gases that don't obey that but you
have to try quite hard it have something
quite weird has to be going on so it is
a pattern and once you learn the pattern
you suddenly have access to all these
different bits of thing
in the world and that's the thing that's
the thing that gets me really excited
about physics it's like a toolbox and
then I realize the consequence of that
realization that sort of way of thinking
about it which is that fundamentally Shh
physicists are really lazy instead of
just learning lots and lots of stuff we
basically learn a small number of
patterns and how to use them and then
everybody else thinks we're kappa we
don't tell them so this is so that's
interesting you know there are it is it
is a relatively small number of patterns
and they give you all of the physical
world and so there was only one equation
there are two graphs so this this we've
got time going to on the bottom here so
this is small time over here
so there's microseconds and things like
that nanoseconds and age of the universe
stuffs down that end and then down the
bottom on this axis you've got small
things down here so this is size and
then big things at the top so in that
traditional view of what physics is and
what physicists study we've got
cosmology which is up there it's very
big it's very far away it's out in the
universe it takes a very long time
and then down this end we've got quantum
mechanics which is very small very fast
far too small to see quite weird and and
it happened extremely quickly so this is
a sort of view of where the frontiers of
physics are but there's a problem
and the problem is that this is all the
things in the real world there's
volcanoes and clouds and coffee stains
and wind turbines and toast and
lightning and clarinets and bubbles and
Jupiter that's Saturn and there or not
quantum they're not general relativity
and cosmology and they are not quantum
mechanics they sit in the middle and
things tend to sit along this sort of
diagonal line so bigger things tend to
be slower and smaller things tend to be
faster and all of these these are not
randomly placed but actually you know
did the Sun and so there's a general
thing it but there's lots and lots of
stuff that can happen in the middle and
so when you add this he's not general
relativity
start out there quantum mechanics starts
down here this huge amount of space in
the middle now it's also not trivial so
they're the frontier of research out
there the frontier of research down here
there's another one in the middle
but it's not just in size and time it's
in complexity because when you take
quite basic simple patterns so Newton
laws Newton's laws of motion
thermodynamics a bit of rotational
dynamics a few of these basic things
they can act together in fascinating
ways that build complex systems
so the third frontier in physics the
thing that we don't talk about when we
don't talk about physics enough is is
this middle frontier here it's
complexity it's generally not very
elegant it's all quite messy but it's
real and this is where we live and
that's why it's important because we
live in the mess of it so I think that
this should get a lot more attention
because this is what's running the world
fundamentally it's the same physical
laws but this is what's going on now
this is an example of some of the things
that are around us in everyday life but
really our current research topics and
those here are some pictures sorry for
the people over there who can't see them
and this is a I still don't know what
this thing is called but it's the thing
that you drizzle honey from if you if
you're into that kind of thing a thought
wouldn't stick with them notches that
you can drizzle - I had a friend when I
was a PhD student at Cambridge I
defended math department who spent his
entire PhD in the math department at
Cambridge studying basically the sort of
twiddling process as honey
yes breeze it's quite quite easy right
starts at the top and that's alright and
it ends up at the bottom in a puddle and
that's all right what happens in between
is genuinely complicated and here's sure
dessert was very important a very
nominal different sort of why you should
tone about that but the point is that
the mathematics of that is current as a
frontier currently physics research
these are bubbles in turbulence and the
water this is what I study and there
this is a sort of thing where there
there is known computer model that camp
to this behavior to a high accuracy we
can do averages and we can do statistics
and we sort of do bulk properties budget
in various ways we can get useful
information out but there's no computer
model that can absolutely simulate the
behavior of a load of bubbles in
turbulence this is the reason I have a
job because we can't do that and yet
this process happens every time you pour
out water into a glass and you see that
little plume of bubbles this is what's
going on and we we've got we understand
a basic physical laws but exactly how
they the details of why a bubble becomes
this shape and not this shape in
practice
that'sthat's a bit trickier and then
this one's quite nice this is egg timer
here and the thing to look at is that
little pile of sand at the bottom so
you'll all be familiar that if you take
him any granular material so it could be
sugar or flour or salts or something
like that
sands and pebbles whatever and you pour
it out it will form a cone and what
happens is it starts flat and the cone
kind of grows like this and then it gets
to a certain angle and it can't get any
steeper so it just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and that
angle what the sort of statistic can be
is called the angle of repose and it
depends on what sort of shape the little
grains are what material they're made
from and how wet they are and all these
little things and there's no simple way
to predict the angle of repose if you
give someone a grain and let them look
at it under a microscope some sort of
inspect it it's actually very difficult
to predict exactly what the angle of
repose is because it depends on you know
how much they interlock and how they
stick together and yet that's the sort
of thing you see in your kitchen and
it's relevant to real real world
problems so all of this is worth looking
at now the first thing is that all these
little everyday things they're not just
toys it's all there's a perception that
it's all just you know that's what you
give the kids to play with when they're
bored on a Sunday afternoon and and I'm
about to that's not that's not right we
should all get to play with them and
this is the reason why so and that to
your video here
one of these eggs is raw and one of them
is boiled and we're going to watch the
video and then you're going to tell me
which one is which this is a relevant
bit in it right which one is raw this
one yeah now isn't that funny because I
bet I did
did anyone as if there's anyone in the
room use not in the way of I mean who
puts boiled eggs back in the fridge but
leaving that aside right has any
apparently some people do it's okay you
couldn't mix in it I would look we've
got a hand up there we can look and
laugh at the Masters and so here's the
thing right um probably not as you may
be a sore by that before but you knew
right you sort of recognize the pattern
when you saw it this one is wrong and
the reason we know it's raw is that you
certain those finish that's all right
and then when you stop you just very
briefly put your finger on the top to
stop it if the egg is solid you stop the
entire thing so it's stopped and at the
end of it if the egg is liquid on the
inside when you put your finger on it
you stop the shell but the liquid on the
inside is still going round there's
nothing to stopped it so that so the
shell stops for a second and then it
gets pushed around by the liquid again
and the principle that this demonstrates
a physicists would call it conservation
of angular momentum and what it means is
that once something is spinning it keeps
spinning unless you do something to stop
it it keeps spinning indefinitely unless
you do something to stop it and the spin
axis will always point in the same
direction and so that's all very useful
if you've got eggs in the fridge and
people do go home and play with a
example this blew me fine but this is
this demonstrates the principle which is
much more important which is this so
this is a picture this thing here is a
picture of the Hubble Ultra Deep Field
because the Hubble Deep Field wasn't
enough and NASA's so the Hubble Space
Telescope has been in space now for more
than 25 years
to take this particular picture so
NASA's analogy for this picture is that
if you took a drinking straw you know
think about that big small and and you
made it two and a half meters long which
is almost the width of this screen and
you've peered at the sky through this
two and a half meter long oh you're
American idea do I have to do it in feet
good you know the no soul-destroying
part of writing the book was when my
American publisher sent me back the
thing it says you have to convert all
into feet
nobody's measured the mass of the Sun in
pounds ever you wasn't convinced so
anyway put it so you don't do your turn
two and a half long straw and and the
bits of the sky that you can see through
the end of it is that right for the shoe
gimmick detail and how we'll have to
basically look at the same bit of sky
for 11 and a half days to capture that
image which is all very nice now Hubble
has been floating in free space not
touching anything for 25 years
how does something that is just floating
cuz it's just nothing to push against
nothing you know what how does that
point at something so precisely how does
it know where to point right that's a
problem and the answer is the only
inside of it it's got something which in
all is exactly the same as a spinning
eggs except sadly it's not actual eggs
right
it's got gyroscopes which are spinning
things and because of the law of the
conservation of angular momentum when
they're spinning they stay spinning in
exactly the same direction there's
nothing to stop them and so Hubble can
kind of effectively move around them and
it's like a 3-dimensional compass so the
same principle that lets you tell apart
a raw egg and a boiled egg by spinning
them also lets the Hubble Space
Telescope orient itself in space it's
the same physics and yet one is seen as
this trivial thing in the kitchen and
one is you know making these images that
make everybody extremely happy and and
the nice thing about these patterns once
you start to spot them is that once
you've got that sort of habit of looking
is that the you spot them in other
places
and that's rewarding and it is realized
so once showed that egg video to a still
talk I don't know the DubLi is a kind of
cool corporate group of people during
the day there's a lot of people in suits
trying to impress their bosses don't
know why I was there but so I did my bit
and I was running my it was running over
a bit in time and so I got to the end I
showed the egg video and some was
peeping at me because I ran over and I
said oh well I won't tell you how it
works you can work it out come and ask
me afterwards and I played off the stage
and and after I had these these great
fully grown middle-aged men literally
tugging at my sleeve saying it is and
they explained I said yes yes it's the
sense of reward doesn't go away when
you're not a child anymore anyway
so what some of the nicest things about
these patterns is that the pick &
Technik tails can take a long time and
when you carry it with you and - until
it's time so the reason of the picture
of blue breeze here is that and I I
lived I lived in the States for five
years and the last two years with in
Rhode Island which is where they grow
lots of blue breeze and I'm from
Manchester in England we don't really
have blueberries and we're not there's
nothing wrong with us we just don't have
blueberries we do now because of
international shipping and things but we
didn't when I grew up so I was
ridiculously excited by the concepts of
lubbers and I and I'd always made lots
of jam like preserves as a kid and I
think be great when I left Rhode Island
to take home bright blue blueberry jam
but the really cool and so I went blue
berry picking and you should all know by
the way that when you go fruit picking
in England if you ever come to England
Britain you have to suffer for fruit
picking in Britain you either have to
bend down and really hurt yourself
you have hurt your back picking
strawberries that are on the floor you
get scratched to pieces by raspberry
canes you've got it so easy in this
country blueberry picking is like
cheating this is west along you know you
picked off west along willow the bushes
and blueberries fall into it with it
anyway so I collected gallons because
you're in America in America right has
to be gallons of zebras I'm not
prejudiced or anything and and the
and then I went you know back to make
this blueberry jam and I you know you
put the sugar and the stuff in the pan
and it's not boiling it up and I waited
for this blue jam to emerge and I'm sure
plenty of you have made blueberry jam
and you know that's not what happens
what happens is that you let the boiling
process happen you put what you put in
start blue what comes out is bright
fuchsia pink which is weird and it's not
blue
I wanted blueberry blueberry blue blue
breeder anyway so I took I took it home
and told everyone is blackberry jam and
they're the most arrested but I was a
bit you know likes what's wrong so six
months later when I was back in the UK I
had a friend who directed history
documentaries and he was making a
documentary about wise women in the 16th
and 17th centuries and they're quite you
know these thieves and women who were
sort of there were one or two in every
village
they were the midwives this has dealt
with people who were ill they sort of
picked up the pieces you know doing all
these little useful jobs and so it's a
lot of folk knowledge but they wrote
things down they were systematic and he
said there are these things that keep
coming up and I'm curious to know if
there's any actual science I mean
they're obviously not touched it testing
for witchcraft which is what they
thought they were doing well maybe
there's something you know maybe this
women going on so there are a few things
that he showed me one of them was that
there was a thing that said if you boil
the first water of the morning which is
urine apparently and it goes to all the
colors of the rainbow then someone is
the witch so I think I think I was
bewitched if that I've been carried
through which if I tried it but I
definitely between two bewitched if it
work and so doing things like that and
and one of those things was that if you
take picture of verbena and verbena is
one of those bright colorful flowers
that you we certainly get a lot of them
in the summer you probably get them here
this bit of the dish neck of the woods
as well and you put it on someone's skin
it changes color then they are bewitched
and I went and had to be able to think
about this and it turns out that the
verbena is you know the bright pearl
and red petals some of them and they the
pigments that make them those bright
vivid colors are a category of chemical
called anthocyanins and they're really
interesting they're commonly lots of
things that you get red cabbage for
example that's got lots of anthocyanins
in it so that not all but a lot of the
bright vegetable pigments are in this
class and the really interesting thing
about anthocyanins is that they act as
pH indicators if you're ever bored get
some red cabbage boil it through the
cabbage away the water is the
interesting bit because it will now be
bright red and you can go around the
kitchen putting it on things highly
entertaining see because it changes
color and and if you put it on something
alkaline it goes blue and if you put it
on a nose but it alkaline it goes yellow
and green if you put it on acid things
it goes red that's right from purple and
change it so alga and it's all depends
on the pan you boil it in as well you
can start with slightly different color
so huge range of colors and and and so I
it I worked out that the your sweat can
change pH depending on what you've been
doing right depending what you've been
eating or what you know your genetics
and and so after it didn't so if I put
teacher of verbena which just means
petals boiled in water on my skin
normally they didn't change color but if
I did it just when I'd been come back
from a run because I spent a while
trying this then they'd change color so
I reckon what those witches were test
witches wise women were testing for was
was actually they had a pH indicator and
they were just testing the pH of
people's sweat which is quite
interesting so we did this whole TV
segment about it and then I remember the
blue Brits from six months beforehand
because as any of you who make Jam know
when you make blueberry jam what goes in
the pan is blueberries and water and
sugar and lemon juice and so the reason
that blue blue jam is bright fuse pink
is that it's basically the entire thing
is acting as litmus paper for the lemon
juice and telling you that it's acid so
I didn't stand the chance of having blue
blue blue young but it was almost worth
it just for that that little sea
you know six months ago all oh that's
why I was doomed to fail that's useful
and and so you build up these patterns
through life through experience as long
as you know you're looking for two and
then they have the more serious so their
consequences now this this is another
little video here the thing to watch is
that doesn't matter they're green the
thing to watch is is how fast the
slopping happens what you're about to
see is a hand come in and just sort of
shape the glasses from side to side is
very glass so it sloshes right we've all
seen sloshing do this but if you look at
the rate of sloshing you'll see that the
the bigger the beer glass the sloshing
happens relatively slowly and the little
vodka shot blasts there the sloshing
happens really really quickly and you
can imagine something further off to
that end if you put water in a bus and
you slosh it it goes really slowly so
there's a lesson here and the lesson is
that in a in a sort of cylindrical
vessel like that and the grease the
bigger the radius is larger the you know
circular top and the slower liquid will
slosh in it if you just disturb it and
let it slosh back to equilibrium and it
turns out it does it does depend mostly
on the radius it depends a little bit on
the depth and a little bit on the shaped
mostly the radius so that's interesting
a lot that's cool this is something
called a natural frequency that any
system that can oscillate if you give it
a bit of a shove it'll have one petition
the rate at which its wings to get back
to to being still and this is the reason
that I spill my tea every day in my
department at University College London
and so the Tea Room is at the end of a
long corridor and I am British there 400
watts tea so every morning and I I'm at
work I'm always in a hurry so I'm never
going at anything less than race places
so I go to the Tea Room and I make my
cup of tea
and I walk I raced back down the
corridor with this thing every morning I
still my tea
and the reason I spill my tea is that my
walking route when you walk you're
effectively there's a bit of a so
regular shaking as there the mug in this
case and and it just so happens that so
you're given the mug a little bit of a
push and if you give something a little
bit of a push at the same frequency as
its natural flushing frequency in this
case and it will make that flushing
really really really big if you push it
it's like pushing a child on a swing if
you push it at exactly the right rate
they'll get higher and higher and higher
if you try and push and push and push
and push and that's too fast for the
swing they just don't go anywhere and
the same if you do it very slowly but if
you hit exactly the right rates then you
get in order to not flushing so it just
so happens that my step rate exactly
nice matches the sloshing rate of my tea
mug and therefore every morning I get
enormous great explosion going on that's
Bill my teeth there are a few reasons
for this I could slow down my option and
I could get a very small cup to start
drinking espresso because then it
wouldn't match but I don't like drinking
coffee I don't use it for experiments I
don't smell of it I buy coffee for all
sorts of things but none of them is
drinking it and the other thing I could
do is I could start drinking hot
chocolate with a layer of foam cream you
know milk on top because the foam
dampens down the oscillations so it kind
of keeps it in which is why beer if
you've got beer with a lot of a head on
it it doesn't get spilt nearly as much
as it should because the the foam
dampens down the oscillations pubs
everywhere I should be very grateful for
that bit of physics anyway so and so
that makes me feel mighty and so there's
this match and this is resonance so
every system has a natural oscillation
rate and if you push it to the exact
nitrate you push the oscillation really
really high that's what's going on
tea oh very nice but then it's got much
more serious consequences so in 1985
there was an earthquake in Mexico City
it caused a huge amount of damage well
the earthquake was off in the Pacific
but Mexico City was was very badly hit
and afterwards your Army Corps of
Engineers went along
have a look at the damage and to see
what lessons could be learned from what
they found in terms of building and
civil engineering and they found
something really interesting they
noticed that buildings below five
storeys high were basically fine
buildings above 20 stories high and
there were lots of them basically fine
it was the world in the middle that fell
over which is weird and so then they had
a look at the actual trace of the
earthquake itself and what happened in
the ground and the geology underneath
Mexico City you probably know is pretty
unusual it's in a big basin so there's
lots of sediment there and it's a very
specific it's sort of got hard base with
this sediment on top and the consequence
of the geology so in earthquake the
shape of an earthquake chasing is
normally quite complicated but the
consequence of the geology in this case
was that the foundations of Mexico City
basically shook at just one frequency so
so the geology amplified one particular
shaking rates and I'm sure you're ahead
of me here buildings tall buildings tend
to sway all the asbestos to do it it's
fine
and each has a natural swaying wave the
taller buildings slower the rate so it
happened in this case that the the
natural frequency the natural swaying
rates of the buildings between five and
20 storeys high was almost exactly the
shaking rate of that particular
earthquake so they're the ones where the
shaking became grew and then they they
fell over so you've got a very important
civil engineering consequence of a
little piece of physics resonance which
you can see in a cup of tea and thing is
once you know about things you can also
do something about them so in this case
not in Mexico but this building here the
Taipei 101 which was for a while that
the tallest building in the world and
until the next tour this one came along
this is quite close to some earthquake
zone if you don't like swaying buildings
this is not the building to go in right
and everybody else is very sensibly not
building so this build it they just mean
extremely clever and I've never visited
it but I would love to go so in the
middle of this building sort of in that
bit that place the third of the way down
from the top inside they put something
fascinating now these these are stories
there's people over there so they put a
gigantic pendulum five stories high
hanging down the middle of the building
and then they spray-painted it gold
because while isn't you and but it can
sway and it is swayed independently of
the building and the reason they put it
that and it's fantastically clever is
that when the so you've got pendulum
hanging pendulum hanging in the middle
when the building is sways that way the
pendulum is kind of left behind and then
as a building sways back the pendulums
caught up and so the building and the
pendulum swaying are sort of throwing
against each other which reduces the
overall swaying of the building to a
third of what it would have been
otherwise and the videos of this thing
it takes about thirty seconds for it to
get from one side to the other but you
can see the videos of other people
watching it during an earthquake and
watching it I mean you'd have to be
pretty interested to be staying what you
are you know so in addition there's a
video on YouTube so you don't have to
and but it's clever right so once you
have these tools of the world you
understand and then you can start to
manipulate what's around you and these
are big important civil engineering
problems not just trivial little toys
and wide outs with your teeth and and
this is this is the fun of science those
of us who are professional scientists
and engineers and really those subjects
are about what you can create using
these patterns and that I mean that's
the fun of it for me I like the finding
finding things out and pushing it things
but the really the game I really enjoy
most is that day when you walk into the
lab and I've got to measure this thing
and I don't know how to do it and I've
got a lab sort of toys to play with what
am I going to do and and it doesn't
always lead where you expect so the
reason that this picture here is here
this is a bit of natural diamonds they
don't often come out
like that this wondered the rock around
it is timber lights which which
surrounds most of it so diamonds
generally formed at the pipes of
volcanoes kimberlite is the rock that
they are very often founded and and the
reason that this picture is here is
because of a friend of mine who was in
my lab when I was a PhD student who was
a New Zealander is a New Zealander
called Jeff very routinely so we all
called him yes and he his job was to
study diamonds being hit very hard so if
he and the game here is if your blast
mining blast lining is a great way to
kind of break up rock the problem you've
got with your blast mining and there's
precious stones in it is that obviously
you want to break up the kimberlite but
you don't want to break your diamonds so
just we're studying how diamonds break
up under impact basically and the way
you do that is you have a thing called a
gas gun which is a in our case tube
about that wide five meters long and you
put your easier to move something that
isn't a diamond so you put your diamond
down listened with high-speed
photography and all kinds of clever
diagnostics like this something over
there down that end is a massive
reservoir of pressurized helium and then
you put this sort of little slug of
plastic and rock in this case here
evacuate all of this so that when you
release the helium it pushes the thing
down here it hits the diamond now a
garrison
I'll just gun can accelerate the
projectile to two kilometers per second
this is a lot of thump and then the gun
was pointed straight at the centre of
Cambridge and so consulted to stop this
causing lots of holes in lots of very
old buildings and the thing here which
was called inventively the cat chamber
and there was a huge metal sort of
chamber on big chains that big heavy
thing and so the idea was and it was
full of rags cloth cotton rags and so
the the projectile would hit the diamond
you gather your photographs the whole
lot disappear after the racks you have a
big sort of flame
is ball of fire as it set the rags on
fire but and the capture chamber would
Swabian on the stump and nothing
there'll be no holes in anything but you
needed all this mass here to absorb the
momentum and you needed some ranks there
in order to just stop sort of contain
everything and the fire helped and so
you needed you needed something in that
I just had a problem and this problem
was that he could take all these
pictures at the instant the diamond
broke up but he wanted to get the bits
of diamond back and the problem is he
never did because they disappeared off
into the ranks with the all the other
mess and the fireball and so he spent a
while trying to work out what he could
do what at which physical tools could
have used how do you solve the problems
we get his bits of diamond back to see
whether they've broken up further down
the line and I will never forget the day
he walked into our lab having come to
the local supermarket with his two big
bags full of strawberry jell-o I had to
think what you called it them and just
you know the stuff just you know for
making desserts from and he plot these
down what are you going to do those are
solutions so his top scientist so spent
two days working out what ratio of
boiling water had to go with the jello
to make the right thing and then he put
that it took all the rags out cleaned
out the cats chamber put some strawberry
jelly because he thought I said because
that was the solution that the idea was
the strawberry jelly would do the job of
the rags and then he could Sibbett I
guess his diamondback and and so he set
this all up it put the diamond down
there evacuated the thing lots of helium
over here and the day came and you know
it should closed everything down and
press the button so the projectile comes
down the bar over two kilometers ahead
second it goes straight into the diamond
smashing its smithereens in the whole
lot disappears off into the jelly and
the capture chamber now what no one had
told him what he hadn't thought to look
up is that when you put it under
pressure
jelly yellow liquefies
and so the whole vat of Thror jelly
instantly liquefied got it out
everywhere and we solidified and you
never got his diamond and you did spend
the next three days clearing up but I
have enormous respect to Jeff I love him
to bits for having done it because if it
had succeeded that would have been the
what a revolution in diamond-catching
technology sometimes it goes wrong right
sometimes you do your best to use the
tools that you've got and it doesn't
work and you learn something right and
that sort of experiment that's all
lateral thinking that's where the real
fun with the tools comes along because
then you can work out ways to do
something with them and and sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't and
either way you learn and you never tried
it again now it's not limited you don't
need a lab and all this sort of fancy
equipment to let critical thinking Drive
what you're doing to learn something
from critical thinking and this guy here
so longer he won the ignoble prize one
of the ignoble prizes in 2009 and some
of you may know the ignoble prizes are
prizes for science that made you laugh
makes you laugh and then makes you think
if you don't know what they are look
them up they're awesome anyway so when
he was 6 or 7 years old his grandmother
caught him cracking his knuckles oh
don't you know I do this with high
school kids and there's mm chills or and
start cracking their knuckles horrible
noise anyway so you know not think
people yourself pulling it up and it
makes a little popcorn noise and and his
grandmother caught in doing that and
said don't do that because if you do
that when you get old you will get
arthritis but he wasn't taking her word
for it so for the next 60 years
this awkward sod Clips the knuckles on
his right hand but not on his left and
at the end of 60 years he didn't have
arthritis in either hand and there is a
scientific paper on it and so it is it's
not necessarily the recommended way
they're doing science but you have to
give him credit for not taking someone's
word for it working out that he could
test it and then having the dedication
to follow through and so it's you know I
don't if he'd been wrong you'd have had
arthritis right um but he learned
something and and there's a lot of
little things in life not necessarily a
serious or as importance is that what
you you can try it you can have a go for
yourself right you can get little
problems you can use some basic
knowledge of the world and you can test
it out and you can test your hypothesis
whether it's right or wrong and just I
can't see the clock back there oh it's
on of those can anyone tell what time is
because I can't see so again 8 10
awesome right I've not I've not okay
I've not run on for too long that moves
what that means good okay now the reason
this is here so that all this stuff
about everyday physics is great but
let's go back to that problem with
complexity so the first thing is
understanding the framework the basic
rules of the world and the reason this
picture is here is that my grandfather
my mother's father was one of the early
television engineers he trained as a
mechanical engineer during the Second
World War and after the war he went to
work for EMI dealing with the early
television and back when he started
electricity was still really an immature
science you know an immature technology
and things went bang and pop and fizz
and exploded and made smells and you
definitely knew there was something
there even if you couldn't see it
there was a very visceral connection to
electricity my mum before I was born was
a computer programmer for Ferranti near
Manchester and very when when she
started she was programming and zeros
and was just about she hates me telling
people that because she thinks it makes
her sound old I think it makes it sound
really cool so I keep telling people
but she was programming right in when
computer Tobi's you could still see what
the computer code is doing right there's
no main loads of paper tape with with
code written on it and then my lab looks
something like that
loads of laptops couldn't really tell
you what they're up to might have
studied the basic principles at some
point and and the problem is that when
you are dealing with this kind of thing
especially with things like touchscreens
yes it's very easy to get taken away
from the basics of the physical world
and yet we still live in it right we've
still got bodies they're about this size
we still have chairs that about same
size toast still Falls butter side down
and this is about the right size for a
piece of toast and the table is going to
be about this high so it's going to
continue to fall but to throw down
however many smartphones you have in the
house but the problem is that this sort
of technology it tricks it lets you be a
little bit lazy for a start because
here's a lot of things that have to
worry about anymore and you can't fix it
anyway arthur c clarke the science
fiction writer once said that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
and an iPad really is as Microsoft
strategy reason is the what's it called
the own surface is them is you know it
has passed that have passed that
boundary by a long way so under but in
contrast to that the Internet makes
possible more access to information than
ever before the problem now is not that
the information isn't accessible if you
don't understand it when you get that
because it's complicated and but that
makes it really important and it's the
way to deal with all this complication I
think the way to start is to understand
the framework because however
complicated something is it still has to
obey conservation of energy
it still has to a conservation of
momentum it still has to obey these
basic rules some lie have done something
very clever to make it happen very
efficiently and make something quite
clever happen but the fundamental rules
of physics are not broken however magic
the device seems and so I think this is
really important because you know it's
there's lots of confusing things in the
world and it's brains it's just too much
information right but the framework when
it comes to the physical world the
framework doesn't change doesn't apply
to economics
economics doesn't have a fundamental set
of physical laws but we have a
fundamental set of physical laws in
physics that are at the root of
everything and you can see them in the
simple things and the same things apply
to the big you know the big important
things like energy supplies and you know
medical testing devices and all that
kind of thing and so so I think it's
really important that we don't
trivialize these toys because that's our
way in a complicated confusing world
noticing these little things about the
world that teaches the basic physical
laws that other that provides a
framework for everything that happens
around us that's an important thing and
everyone can try it the time I knew when
I might have might done something useful
with the book so I gave it to I'm a
badminton player probably most of you
never heard of that sport I don't know I
like it
and better my club in Wimbledon in
London is you know lots of people there
they know me as an athlete they don't
you know know much about my science so
they're very good for constructive
feedback
and I sense one of the draft chapters to
one of my friends at badminton and I got
a text message back from a few weeks
later and it said so he was working
overseas in Switzerland and it said the
text message said I'm sitting at
breakfast in a posh hotel in Switzerland
I really want to push toast off the
table because I don't believe what you
wrote and that's the good bit it doesn't
have to believe me he can just annoy the
waitress right but he's free to push
toast off the table and watch it happen
for himself and if he doesn't agree with
me you can push toast off the table in
front of me and we'll both look at the
evidence and you know look but it's then
not been accessible right it's right
there and you can play with it and it
just takes a bit of habit and a bit of
confidence because physicists are not
very good about you know sharing I think
the idea that this isn't just about
knowing things it's about your
perception of the world that you your
perception of things changes and you
walk around carrying that and it's very
useful and no one tells you that so so
I've told you now - you all know
and so I'll skip that bit right so
that's it um the other thing that isn't
going away is the complexity having
dealt with the fact that maybe we can do
something about those foundations the
other thing we have to deal with once we
understand the framework is is being
comfortable with ambiguity and being
comfortable with the difference between
not knowing everything and knowing
nothing there is this picture says so
horizon is a long very long running
series of BBC science shows and we made
one in 2004 this is that's me in one of
Britain's weather forecasters John
Hammond and we made this horizon so we
had an unusual few unusual winters of
weather in 2013-14 and we made this show
about why that happened and if the BBC
if the BBC had ever understood how
complicated the answers to the question
was they wouldn't have let's make the
show so we didn't tell them and because
there's all these things weather is
complicated right you know you've got
and you get this a lot here because you
your your weather map includes a lot
much larger areas and our but you know
you've got an El Nino doing things
you've got the Jetstream doing things
you've got something called equator
biannual oscillation going on over the
equator you've got the North Atlantic
Oscillation all these different things
going all these patterns overlaid on
each other and so we understand a lot
about the weather we don't understand
everything we can't with this weather
scientists can't piece together why this
why these winters were particularly bad
but it's not as simple as a causes B
causes see it's oh well this happened
and that happened and that overlaid with
that and it corresponds of that hard to
predict in advance but afterwards you
can kind of trace back and the important
thing is that there's a huge difference
between not knowing anything and having
having that source of knowledge can't
say it in two sentences but there's a
huge amount of understanding and I think
there's a sort of there's a point coming
up where this is what science is like
now they all the interesting bits are in
that complicated bit in the middle and
the problem with the company
is that the foundations are still the
same you can explain the basis of
whether with the gas law and
thermodynamics and various or the simple
patterns when it comes to the
intricacies of how they play out you use
the same rules to explain it but it
takes you know a long essay and not two
sentences and you have to put a little
bit more work into putting all the
pieces together so in order to trust the
weather forecast fundamentally you have
to trust the system that the weather
forecast is based on and the system is
science the system is we've got some
evidence we're going to test the
hypothesis against it we're going to
revise our opinions and get some more
evidence and there's a work our way
through it and so because things are
complicated you have to trust where it
comes from and in order to trust the
overall thing so being comfortable with
uncertainty and understanding the you
know what it means to have understanding
of a complex system I think that that's
a very important thing because there is
never going to be an answer it's just
one thing so on a slightly more cheerful
note and I think each of us has three
life support systems a body our own body
our planet and our civilization and each
of them is keeping us alive in its own
way and they're independent systems and
for example one of the reasons that
climate change is an issue is that it's
two of these life support systems
butting up against each other we've got
our planetary system which takes long
and we rely on it being as it is because
it keeps us alive as it is now and then
we've got our infrastructures and
civilization which keeps us alive in
terms of supplying food and water and
growing enough stuff and all that kind
of thing and we have to negotiate that
boundary and but each of these like I
mean so there's always reasons for
studying science which are you know
anything that's funny you can play with
eggs and it satisfies curiosity and it
all those kind of stuff and but when if
you're a little pragmatic than that and
this is the reason for doing it is that
if you're not interested in anything
else you're probably still interested in
keeping yourself alive and the rules
that keep these life-support systems
going all the basic rules of the
physical world but the patterns of
physics that you can see in your kitchen
so it's probably quite important to
understand them and these all end up
being quite complicated systems but the
fun we can the fundamental layers of
understanding are built from the same
things and so that that's why you know
if you're not convinced by physics just
being interesting hopefully you're
convinced by that as a reason I think
reading the study things too and so you
know this is the kind of class like
environment country homework so things
you try at home to get you started on
playing with toys
so lemonade in Britain I need to change
that for for us audiences we are very
unsophisticated with lemonade what that
should say is soda because in Britain we
call stuff lemonade that has never been
near a lemon and but you are better than
that sometimes so brightness and count
so anyway
bottles whatever two litres is here
baccala fizzy stuff and take the label
off so you can see sticks and raisins in
the top watch what happens it's very
interesting also very good at parties if
you're with boring people and pick the
raisins out of the bar snacks and find
yourself a fizzy drink it's got to
affect it makes the boring people go
away and it makes it interesting people
come to you so you win both ways and
still some coffee and let it leave it
alone take a picture of the spill and
then come back a bit later and take a
picture of what's happened to it
afterwards when it's dried there's a
really important difference in you've
all seen and that is worth looking at
and get a teaspoon if you can't live
with the mess get a teaspoon and get a
ceramic code coffee mug and tap it taps
around the rim and listen that's a good
thing to do and push some toast up a
table because you might as well there
are way and see if you want to extend
that one and see if you can find a way
to knock it off in a way that it doesn't
always fall butter side down it's messy
right there is a physical solution it is
quite messy but it's worth trying
so I'm going to stop talking
and we have time for questions but
that's me done thank you you come and
ask at the microphone and keep your
question in the form of a question
thank you and feel free to ask about
anything I mean anything within reason
you need a race going on here he's going
to get there first go go oh god he's got
notes how do you develop the practice of
finding patterns so that again thought
how you the process of finding patterns
how do you practice smooth how do you
practice yeah so what my publisher would
say read the book but by um you you
start by looking at it it starts with
looking for things that are that other
questions of kids would ask and then
looking up why that's in the modern
world that's the easiest way to do it
that you and it's a habit it's really
hard to unsee the things that you or to
refuse you've stopped yourself seeing so
but once you spot one hold on to it
right you'll have those little thoughts
that drift through your mind that that
say oh oh it's not old and it starts
with at that point not dismissing it
right file it away you'll see something
right and even if it's you know
contrails in the sky or the way that
ripples travel across a pond there'll be
some little thing you all this build
hold onto that and then look at why it
happens that's the first bit better than
looking it up if you could look you
could try and think of reasons for
yourself and you know play with it a bit
but it starts with catching the thought
but adults are always suppressing things
right that's what part of the process of
growing up and being an adult is that
there's too much complication in the
world so your brain just you know you
learn to suppress anger and you learn
specification and either you know
we put the lid on yourself when it comes
to science take the middle and just hold
on to what came out so that's the place
to start and yeah those are enough that
yes
I'm over there I'm not sure the British
practice of making tea but I was
wondering if there's a teabag involved
on your walk back to your office and if
that would be analog to that pendulum in
the building so he are so the way the
the tea bag has got two effects it could
have actually the first thing is that if
you make tea properly you take the
teabag out before you put the milk in I
wish someone would teach Starbucks stuff
anyway
so if in an industrial setting this
flushing process what what one of the
common ways of preventing it is to put
baffles in the container which is to put
in things that stick out and are
obstacles to the sloshing movement so
inside under water so the tea but a tea
bag would definitely do that yeah so if
you can face the washing up the way you
know what you want some little shelves
coming out on the inside that's what an
industrial engineer would do who didn't
have to do the washing up and the other
thing you can do is have a have a cup
that mug that kind of comes around a
little bit hold the sloshing in and then
what else for the tea banku that sort of
thing it would you would get a bit you
would get a bit of swaying but the
swaying there's an interesting thing
there with inertia let me think about
that for a bit because the tea bag isn't
free to sway in the same way that the
pendulum is and so it's range of motion
would be very limited maybe it might
depend on whether you had a pyramid tea
bag or a flat one on which way it was
oriented you go in you should see the
experiments and I think I think the
major effect would be acting as a baffle
and just moot getting in the way of the
fluid trying to move past it because in
order for that sloshing to happen the
fluid underneath has to move as well
it's not just a bit on the top the fluid
all the way down is actually shifting a
little bit so if you stopped that
process
so that would be my guess but then
that's so we can all do the experiment
now go home next time you have some tea
and and the other thing that Igor I
could do just a little bit is reduce the
depth of the mug effectively if it was
sitting on the bottom so lots of
experiments to do I don't know the
answer but you can all go and try that's
the best I can do with that yes hi there
so that's quite interesting like job
application of physics your friend in
this case blasting diamond parts and
then trying to analyze that I'm sure it
happens both ways but when you're a
physicist you're looking for a job I
mean do you typically find more often
those you get the one crazy idea and
you're just going to make a job of it
and get someone to pay you for it or do
you find it more often after you decide
that you like this bit of physics that
now I'm just going to search for jobs in
this arena people don't always pay us to
play with toys that is a sad thing
so yeah exactly boo and what normally
happens is that it's driven by an
application so it depends on what the
zena's pure physics research and applied
physics research and ideally you're
always doing a little bit both the pure
stuff is when you see an interesting
thing and you go after it the applied
one is when of the problem and you find
ways to solve it and when you're an
academic physicist you you you can do
all the experiments you like as long as
you can find a way to pay for them so
there's always a bit of a balance it's
not like you go after I mean it depends
so there's so many answers to that
question but normally you create an
opportunity to let you do something
interesting and assume it's going to
take you to the next interesting thing
so it's not like you go after a single
goal you go oh here's interesting thing
and that takes you to another singer
them and so you turn jobs into what you
want to because you're interested in
what you're good at you know what your
mother interest you will be coming you
work out never you're good at it and
then takes you along that so it's not
like you get to pick there's no simple
answer to that same procedures yeah
thank you
just for the record no any all question
is so far have been very homogeneous
their gender if any other people know
they haven't that's not quite true
they've been quite homogeneous but not
complete but let's have a mix of people
coming to the microphones and right go
on your settle out yeah okay I get I get
it you have to at least get me started
with the toast things so I think what's
going on is that the the butter has a
greater mass and there's nothing to do
with the butter oh okay you can try it
without butter on it Wheatley office
right I haven't got a clue but you see
you could have but you see you could
have all it was all it would have taken
right it's for you not just to do the
thinking but actually to go and get two
pieces of toast and put butter on one
I'm not on the other and watch right
it's not about I'm Tyrell constantly
trying to teach my students not to
especially the young ones not to think
they can sink to a problem and just get
to an answer you've got to check along
the way against reality so before you go
off about thinking up some enormous
hypothesis about whether it's about the
butter what you do is you try it with
butter and without and you see if
there's a difference and if there isn't
then you get off the topic of the butter
basically so this sort of like you know
human droids trying to keep trying to
think part of the discipline of science
is not thinking too many steps ahead
you've got to prioritize the first
problem and check and then you find out
whether the next problem is worth
worrying about
and so yes sorry to shoot you down but
not that butter yes your gender question
actually picked up something I was
thinking about that picture wonderful
picture of all the men in physics and
then you how do you get more women
involved in physics so it really is it
could be very exciting and there that is
a question that's got an hour-and-a-half
answer which I will spare you but there
are the first thing everyone can do if
you're interested in this is read a book
called delusions of gender by Cordelia
fine and it's about the socialization of
brains and how fundamentally above
everything else humans are social
creatures and we behave
we are programmed almost to behave in
the way that we think people expect us
to behave and so the gender having a
gendered society creates problems that
are very hard to escape because your
your brain is constantly even though
you're not aware of it saying what what
am I expected to do so the first thing
is everybody needs to read that book
which is reference to the hill to
various solid academic references the
biggest thing is changing the
environment so science has traditionally
being seen as something which is it's
about right and wrong it's almost an
aggressive our way or the highway type
thing and it's not traditionally seen as
being about conversations and the manner
in which a lot of physics departments
and engineering departments still
operate is very old-school aggressive
male and changing that culture is the
biggest single thing that will change a
number of women in physics and that
involves the men accepting that making
modernizing the workplace is better for
everybody it's not doing things for the
women it's modernizing something which
makes it better for everybody there I'm
very proud to work in the department at
UCL where the people who go home you
know for a clock to collect their kids
in and make up the hours later other men
not the women so I think really there's
lots of types of diversity that you know
we do not have a diverse scientific
workforce and that is a huge problem but
making it better is about making the
system better for all humans we need to
work harder and in very specific ways
for some for some sectors of society but
the act that the idea has to be pushed
forward by everyone because it's better
not because it's giving something to
somebody else or you know sort of
creating friction it's better for
everyone
so it's an attitude thing and there's
all these things about the leaky
pipeline and you know stereotypes and
why women stop doing it and there was a
report that was published in Britain
three or four years ago but suggested
evidence at the moment the reason women
don't leave we reason women leave
physics is because they thought better
things to do they can do the technical
stuff and the social skills so there you
go they go off and get paid huge amounts
of money to work in industry and so
there's lots of ways of looking at it
but but that attitude change that it's
it's it's a modernization process and
it's not optional and the culture change
has to be taken very seriously
that's a hard people assume everyone
thinks their thing is normal right and
there's a lot more listening needed
about different ways of the way you can
run science so yeah it's a hard problem
over there family
our last two question last few questions
them so I know that that the quantum
mechanics things a very small follow one
set of laws or things that are very
large follow another set of laws can you
talk about sort of the stuff in between
and what laws they follow so there is
there's yeah so the interesting thing
about scaling laws in physics is that
all of the forces are present all of the
time but there's always a sort of
hierarchy of priority so for example
where I am standing on stage gravity is
the force which is making most
difference to my body immediately you
know there are electrostatic forces as
the strong force and the weak force of
surface tension and disgusting as the
air and all kinds of things but gravity
dominates because of this size so all of
the forces are always there so shear
forces from viscosity for example I can
move my hand around but the viscosity of
the air is basically negligible so that
doesn't make any difference but if you
were to make my hand really really small
the viscosity of the air suddenly starts
to matter more than the gravity that I
need to resist to hold my hand up so as
you make things smaller and faster
exactly the same laws are there but
different ones are at the top of the
hierarchy and so that's why a towel for
example if you or you know if you get to
some absorbent
and you put it in a puddle the liquid
will only soak up so far and the
structure of the towel is what dictates
how far that is
but if you've got something that was
quite big like a kind of play frame with
great big holes this big you put it in a
puddle nothing would go anywhere so it's
all about the hierarchy basically and
the same simple source of supply and
they're the ones that don't matter are
so insignificant most of the time that
we can completely discount them to a
good approximation so it's an
interesting problem because you shift
and it becomes very interesting when you
do things like working out what life
would be like on another planet because
you there you have the same physical
laws but you've got different you know
they've got different values so the
hierarchy could be different even for
something my size so it needs to all
this interesting for the speculation
about how you operate in different
environments and the first example is
the ocean because if you want alien life
don't bother going to Mars just go to
the bottom of the ocean far interesting
right oh sure sure we're running out of
time a little bit here yes go on last
question
so one comment to the gender thing is
giving women the opportunity to rise to
the challenge so challenging women to
come up and ask questions is the first
thing that actually gets us stuff here
to do it so just one comment on that my
question was very similar to her so I'm
going to switch it up a little bit and
do you think that we have all the tools
necessary to create a universe of
universal theory of everything and is
that possible and old philosophy let's
finish on philosophy and so universal
theory of everything has there are there
are different interpretations of what
that means at its broadest sense it's a
set of consistent theories that explain
everything we see experimentally a
theory of everything the grand unified
theory is this thing where quantum
mechanics and general relativity has to
mesh but they don't play nicely with
each other
black holes are you know one thing tiny
quantum stuff is another thing and they
might be quite far apart those two
theories don't have to talk to each
other until you get inside a black hole
or back at the beginning of the universe
as a set of grand unified theories we
know that quantum mechanics and general
relativity cannot go
be perfectly right because they have to
talk to each other at some point and at
the moment they can't do it so there's
that kind of grand unified theory where
there's some some modification needs to
be found but no one's quite found where
the matching process is when it comes to
the bigger question of how you how
whether a theory of everything is
possible I think that history is
littered with scientists who thought
that it was just about the tidying up
now we've basically found anything it's
just about tidying up so scientists for
the surprises I think that it the thing
that the thing the reason I'm hesitating
is that for it to be science it has to
be testable for you to have a theory it
has to be testable and a lot of theories
about the universe and multiverses and
things like that it's very difficult to
test them so it may be possible to have
series of explain everything we see but
there could be two of them that both
explain everything we see and we cannot
distinguish between them because we
can't create an experiment because we
can't go outside our own universe for
example so it is likely that something
will not be testable but it doesn't mean
that we can't get very very close and
the Sun I can't think of anything worse
than science as a friend of mine once
said very very well science knows it
doesn't know everything because
otherwise it would stop and it'll be
it's such fun to do and it's such a fun
journey to go on but it would be a
terrible thing if it was to stop because
it wouldn't be fun so maybe I hope we
don't ever find a theory of everything
because then we'll keep having fun and
maybe that's a good place to finish
[Applause]
[Music]